am dritten tag der belastungs übung
werden treffen verschiedene
gefechtssituationen geübt und es wird
immer härter dauerbelastung wenig schlaf
und nun auch noch der wetterumschwung
regen und kälte
es ist still im lager die erschöpften
soldatinnen und soldaten schlafen tief
und fest
doch plötzlich ein alarm mitten in der
nacht der befehl lager wechseln
und nach dem lager wechsel auch schon
die tagwache der wegen passt zu
morgenstimmung 11 ca lager wechselt uhr
begonnenen lager abbauen
nun soll wieder alles aufgebaut um 233
sondern wieder nicht selten gewesen und
zum teil schon wieder alarm der regel
selbst alter bis alles los ist
versuch mal bis zum super falcon also
trocken bleiben schlafen bin ich noch
mit einer klage vor eingeteilt war
sicherungsposten zur fahrzeugführer nach
jetzt eine frühe halter wegen dieses er
bis zur leistungsbewertung mahner
ein paar motivierende worte vom
ausbilder sollen die truppe aufheitern
doch einem soldaten plagen noch
zusätzliche sorgen
johann hat während des marsches gestern
bis lager wechsels oder oder ein volles
magazin mit knall munition verloren
es heißt heute in der früh drauf komme
ein vollzähliges abwehr und auf hin oder
natürlich das gelände in seinem bereich
abgesucht und des gefunden
problem gelöst auf geht's zur ersten
gefechtsübung des tages genau das
richtige wetter um mutter zu werden
in ober treffen sollen heute
verschiedene gefechts ausschnitte geübt
werden
frau zugführer bei klar nutzt die
möglichkeit ihre blasen behandeln zu
lassen
er ist ok danny wilde eigentlich nie
bloßen körper - am montag das sofa
rutschen die radfahrer hinrich und das
wird die usa eigentlich wäre für heute
ein hubschraubertransport angesagt
gewesen doch das schlechte wetter und
tiefer nebel machen einen strich durch
die rechnung ja wir hören jetzt
kurzfristig mit erinnerung
aufgrund der wetterlage der helikopter
nicht fliegen kann bei einem nebel geben
werde eine station einen kontrollpunkt
das ist im prinzip eine zutritt
regelungen für einen gewissen verfügungs
raum
das bundesheer diesen bezogen hat und
einfach sicherstellen will dass nur
berechtigte personen diesen betreten
welcher sender personen und
fahrzeugkontrollen durchgeführt
ob die person im ausweis losungswort
oder von der gemeinde einen
passierschein mit hat was diese
berechtigtes diesem bereich zu betreten
wenn es nach dem ausbilder geht ist
zugführer fröhlich noch ein wenig zu
autoritär
anhalten war gut aber dann viel erfolg
geblieben
abflug sowie zivilisten möglich
politiker beträgt mit der sperrgebiete
geht es der gemeinde informieren sich
die untergebenen es liegt daher auf der
bundesliga direkt und abfluss oder
machen die kritikpunkte war das ihr ziel
personenverkehr innerhalb zu direkt muss
man immer verhältnismäßig sein kind auf
die lage im einsatzgebiet an drauf an
wie man es den antrag aber genau dafür
wird ja auch geübt
nächste aufgabe ein riegel wird geübt
mit dem unterschied zu gestern das
wetter das wetter kann natürlich zum
spielverderber werden wenn die
verhältnisse gut sind agieren alle
leichter kälte und vor allem die nächste
dringen ein und mit den ganzen
physischen und psychischen belastungen
die die lehrgangsteilnehmer haben auf
dieser übung wird das natürlich um
einiges erschwerend und man wird sehen
aus der erfahrung heraus geholfen sich
dann doch die ausfälle dazu noch
zusätzlich
zurück in ober treffen übernimmt
wachtmeister ladner die funktion des
gruppen kommandanten zeigen drei tage
belastung schon wirkung dass ich noch in
einer annehmbaren verfassung bin gut ist
es sicher immer aber ich glaube es gibt
doch schlechteres oder beziehen sich auf
seine schlechtere es gibt also gut im
schnitt
aufgabe der gruppe ist ausstellungen für
die verteidigung zu erkunden stellungen
zu beziehen und diese mit sandsäcken
auszubauen
klingt doch ganz einfach doch zuerst die
planung ja dadurch dass wir alle in
einem kommandanten schulung sind muss
jeder einstellung skizzen zeichnen und
muss sich jeder mal gedanken machen
über's gelände und einmal gelände lesen
lernen
wachtmeister weiß die stellungen zu und
gibt den kampfauftrag hauptaugenmerk
soll entlang der straße vor rechtliche
grenze die sich zum 15
runde aufeinander geht hinter der straße
gefunden was vor bereich rechte grenze
ist da diese richtung 10
der brite waren quasi von links wenn
gefordert nach mördern und hilfe und
vorher einstellen wenn keine wirkung
mehr ein ziel entfernt vernichtet oder
vergibt und los geht's
bezogen
nach gelungener übung erreicht die
gruppe das nachtlager ein letztes mal
werden die zelte aufgestellt schlaf wird
es nach dieser nacht für die nächsten 48
stunden nämlich nicht mehr geben
am donnerstag die noch durch das heißt
wir schlafen nicht mehr
sie gehen sondern auch nicht freitag zum
schauen und hoffen dass wir weiterhin
patienten
aber man hört ja grundsätzlich heißt
zweimal noch schlafen und in den 1 das
einmal schlafen zwei tage heißt es halt
was anderes
ja ich glaube der schwerste teil liegt
uns noch bevor und solange heute nicht
überwunden haben ist von entspannung
glaube ich noch nie angst die räder
das heißt wenn das überwunden ist dann
kann ich mich entspannen in der dusche
beabsichtigt den feldbacher speziell
woche
die sicherung selbst voller und das
zustand der truppe deren wichtigsten
bezogen zeltaufbau formiert suchen
stellvertreter und wohlstand wunder
die entscheidende frage wie ist das
wetter ja das sonnig und warm osama
honig und war noch nichts anderes gelbe
fehlt es wird einen alarm geben muss die
magic brandeinsatz führung vorüber aber
sonst werde die gruppe jetzt wie muss
ich schon sagen sie die klasse jetzt in
ruhe lassen ja hoffentlich keiner diese
seine größte befürchtung jetzt erweist
onassis und sie hat einen ganzen tag
unterwegs wenn das niveau am gewesen
aber sie habe ich keine chance dass sie
wirklich wärmen können und äußert wie
sie miteinander umgehen umziehen wo es
gibt dann häufig fuchsen heute natürlich
in der klasse gesungen dann
protektionismus aus protest aus dass es
im leben halt voneinander anschauen
zwei tage lang ohne nachtruhe müssen die
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer zurück
nach enns marschieren und sich dieser
herausforderung stellen wie sie sich
beim härtesten teil der belastungs übung
schlagen zeigen wir in folge 5